ich will dass sie nicht
team süd hat es fast geschafft
es ist in potsdam angekommen die stadt
liegt kurz vor berlin
hier steht das wunderschöne schloss
sanssouci mit seinen parks friedrich der
große liegt hier begraben
als könig hatte die kartoffel nach
deutschland geholt
tauscht die kartoffel in immer
wertvollere dinge ein
ihr dürft fünf mal tauschen und misst am
schluss einen wertvollen gegenstand
haben als das andere team
es ist also ein duell
erstmal muss team süd tauschen nächstes
mal bekommt team nord auch eine tausch
aufgabe in einer anderen stadt
team süd startet im holländischen
viertel nicht gehen
es gibt gegner mit den nudeln geht es
weiter aber im moment sind die gassen
ziemlich leer
den kindern sektflasche als nächstes
probieren sie ihr glück in einem
andenkenladen ob hier jemand sagt mark
für den sekt gibt es friedrich den
großen als puppe lange können die drei
die puppe aber nicht behalten
hier möchte das team sie gegen einer
holzschatulle tauschen
nasa will jetzt mogeln das team schreibt
etwas auf das preisschild der schatulle
überlegt wenn wir ein null schreiben
300 touristen
das wäre natürlich betrug aber offenbar
sind die leute in potsdam schlauer als
massa glaubt 150 euro dem mann gehört
ein restaurant in potsdam für die
schatulle bietet er einen gutschein für
ein essen 30
christina jonas und nasse haben es
geschafft eine kartoffel in ein
abendessen für 150 euro einzutauschen
nicht schlecht aber noch gibt es kein
ticket denn in der nächsten folge tritt
auch team nord mit einer tausch aufgabe
an
sie nicht
hier geht's